it's not a luxury car but the 350
mustang gt350 came out with its kind of
teaser video today and I feel like it's
going to be the biggest car at the show
I think it might be the biggest car to
come out for a few months I mean we're
talking about a lot of new technology
that we haven't seen on Ford's before
magnetic ride technology a flat plane
crank shaft which means it's gonna sound
like a Ferrari all of these great things
that we've never seen from Ford before
so I'm super excited it looks great it's
gonna be fast it's gonna finally rival
the z28 camaro which is something that
for it hasn't done in the wine well and
I wonder if it will finally rival the
Corvette I've always asked I always
asked Alan before on Mullally and I
asked mark fields now why don't you put
something out that rivals the vet
because you have nothing in that slot
and they always kind of say well we feel
like Mustang does pretty well there this
is a car that I could imagine if I were
in the market for a big v8 front-engine
muscle I would imagine buying this car
yeah I think so and we'll see where the
prices because I still think it's gonna
come in a little bit lower than the
Corvette certainly than the zo6 but yeah
I think that that's a fair purchase
decision between like a bassy 7 and this
because one of the great things about
the Corvette is at its had magnetic ride
it's had the magnetic dampers which have
been able to get on a lot of cars short
of like an audi r8 or cuz the
applications howdy one else has to
license that technology from GM right
from actually to chinese company that
bought delphi now but it was originally
GM technology i see let's talk about the
big luxury a sort of Pullman car that's
coming out at least we hear a rumor that
there's gonna be a Pullman a Maybach
Pullman type car coming out for mercedes
what do you hear about that yeah i hear
the same thing and i think it's actually
a really great brand strategy for
mercedes because you're starting to see
mercedes / mg r dash AMG Mercedes dash
my back and because Mercedes is its own
brand competing against fans brands like
Volkswagen Audi group which is like five
against one because it's Volkswagen Audi
Lamborghini you have all of these
different brands competing Mercedes now
says hey Mercedes is our best brand but
you can get a higher end one so if
you're some wealthy dude and Dubai who
wants the best you could say oh well
you've got a mercedes benz or miss
Abby's AMG I've ever Sadie's my back so
the my buck will go up against say
Bentley enrolls Bentley from Volkswagen
rolls-royce from BMW the AMG can go up
against say Portia from Volkswagen or
I don't know what else AMG would go up
against I guess the AMG a karate
actually Maserati that's where they're
trying to position that brand so it
gives it something that Fiats apparently
gonna have going forward it gives it
something we're Audi sort of is in that
space and hiring when you look at the
the higher-end Audi vehicles and also
sort of the lower in bentley products it
gives it something there that he didn't
really have before so I just wanted to
talk quickly about the AMG GT because
your staff writer Damon lav ring got to
try it at Laguna Seca some journalists
are getting it out there this week and I
hope to get a glimpse of it people are
talking about it is like a possible
Porsche killer here you can see a
picture of it in yellow which is I guess
AMG's favorite color yeah it's that
weird i think imola yellow they call it
yeah I think that it gives them
something that if you look at the market
now the f-type is the only vehicle net
sort of Audi TT sort of nicer space BMW
z4 this room luxury sports car that's
actually grown the F types grown a huge
amount i think we're sadie saw this saw
that 911 s actually outsold Cayenne zand
Panamera's last month and they said
lower into the markets probably not
where you want to be slk sales have been
terrible this year but we can actually
probably make up a lot of value and get
customers that we've sort of lost the
Bavarians by our the other Bavarians by
doing this so but this will be in a
price class that's above an f-type and
probably more like a Porsche 911 Turbo
yeah it's gonna be above an f type but
not that much when you start if you
start speaking ahead type it actually
catches up with the 911 almost
immediately very few people are buying
sort of the v6 base f types even though
if it's actually a great car so yeah
we're seeing in this in a really
high-end space and what I'm curious now
though is that you look at like the
Corvette we're talking with a Corvette
earlier the zo6 is so competitive and
it's so fab fast and it's not as nice as
a Mercedes but I'm curious if now all
these German car companies gonna have to
start worrying about the Americans well
and this is it kind of a not an argument
that i had with Damon but on your site
you know the at least the Corvette you
can still get a stick shift in whereas
the Mercedes you have to drive it with
the paddles so